[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qu'on réalise pas
qu'on a jusqu'à temps qu'on t'en es fou
c'est à ce moment là que tu réalises
toutes les sphères de sa vie que ça la
fict l'odorat sophie cherche à le
retrouver depuis quatre mois dans la vie
de tous les jours c'est un peu bizarre
parce qu'on a l'impression vivre quelque
chose que les autres réalisent pas que
tu vis est peu visible aux gens autour
de toi
cette étudiante globe trotteuse qui
adore l'odeur des huiles essentielles et
du café fait partie des deux tiers des
gens qui ont perdu l'odorat
après avoir contracté la copie quand
j'ai pris ma douche un matin en me
levant un vandale à l'école je sentais
pas les mises essentiel que je viens à
tous les matins on estime des personnes
qui ont perdu l'odorat suite l aco vite
à peu près 90% le retrouve assez
rapidement à l'intérieur de quelques
jours quelques semaines mais que 10% des
personnes ont un trouble de l'odorat à
plus long terme le docteur frace nelly
s'intéresse à la perte de l'odorat chez
des personnes atteintes de lakovic 19
leurs anneaux smi est le résultat de la
tacc des cellules de soutien à
l'intérieur du nez par le coronavirus
toutes les pistes elle marche active des
fonctions plus et aussi les neurones ne
fonctionne plus et l'information seront
plus au cerveau
[Musique]
ce qui me manque le plus aujourd'hui
c'est l'odeur de mes deux fils c'est
l'odeur du parfum de mon papa c'est et
c'est l'odeur aussi du corps de ma femme
jean michel a perdu l'odorat à la suite
d'un accident il y à plus de 5 à ce
handicap il s'installe dans les mois et
les années qui passent et ils vous
éloignent un petit peu de vos proches
qui vous éloigne de la vie tout court
pour tenter de retrouver ce sens et les
plaisirs qui en découlent il entame des
recherches et se rend vite compte qu'il
existe très peu d'informations sur le
sujet ce qui m'a mené donc a rencontré
des tas de gens qui gravitent autour de
l'odorat de la noce mis des chercheurs
des médecins et donc j'ai créé
l'association il ya trois ans et
maintenant évidemment le coc vide à
donner un effet de booster fallait j'ai
beaucoup de difficulté à trouver
l'information surtout en français au
québec
j'aide promet un latté s'il te plaît un
peu découragés se fit retrouvent espoir
lorsqu'elle découvre le site web de
l'association à nos semis point org avec
une fondue par jean-michel de pouvoir
lire les forums les échanges je
participe à des conférences de voir les
témoignages de ces gens là monsieur
permet de comprendre un peu plus comment
ça fonctionne de redonner espoir aussi
que des pistes de solution que tu peux
faire
elle apprend également que l'association
propose un protocole pour retrouver le
dorat est ce que tu pourrais faire une
bonne pédagogue pour offrir un cadeau
café l'eucalyptus rose citron clous de
girofle et menthe poivrée six huiles
essentielles bien précises a eu mais
chaque jour pendant 12 semaines
un protocole qui consistent simplement
entraîné son odorat à favoriser le
renouvellement des neurones olfactifs
par la sollicitation matin et soir à la
veille dans un premier temps puis dans
un deuxième temps en regardant ce que
l'on va sentir inspiré par des travaux
publiés en 2009 à nos semis point org a
adapté ce protocole en collaboration
avec plusieurs spécialiste orl et
chercheur en neurosciences français
cette ré éducation rigoureuse
quotidienne très longue c'est vrai sur
12 semaines
il faut la faire parce qu'elle donne des
résultats et aucun danger et ça
nécessite aucun médicament c'est rien
d'inconnu en fait sophie est confiante
que la rééducation olfactives
fonctionnera pour elle c'est pourquoi
elles se préparent à commencer le
protocole très bientôt en ce moment
l'intervention la plus prometteuse qu'on
a on pense que cette rééducation
effective l'entraînement le factiva
vraiment renforcé ses de régénérescence
à partir des cellules souches récupérer
quelques pour cent et quelques
sensations ça égaye tout de suite un
quotidien et une vie finalement parce
que je le rappelle l'odorat c'est avant
tout le sens des émotions
si la perte de l'odorat et souben la
démarche pour le retrouver peut s'avérer
longue et ardue
je vais vraiment mettre les chances de
mon côté puis voir si ça peut donner un
résultat positif et mes filles sophie
s'accrochent à cet espoir de retrouver
ses petits plaisirs de la vie
si cher à ses yeux